розпочалося все з однієї дівчинки
артилеристки Я почала шукати зрозуміла
що в нас не те що жоден виробник ніколи
не відчував жіночу форму у нас навіть
немає представлених брендів Які би
купували цю форму за кордоном наприклад
з Америки тому що в Америці вони дуже
прогресивні вони з 2009 року почали
розробляти жіночу форму а в Україні
навіть вона не представлена Ну ви можете
її на амазоні замовити але ви її там
дочекаєтеся з урахуванням того періоду
часу і логістики Ну так в місяці Через
три я була дуже здивована мені навіть
якщо чесно так не вкладалося сильно в
голові чому виробники які виконують
державні замовлення на рівні
Міністерства оборони жодного разу просто
не створили щось для жінок а роками
дівчата отримували форму в армії вони її
перешивали причому якщо На той період
часу собівартість форми була там десь до
1,000 грн от Вони наймали швею чекали
там 10 днів і платили дві з половиною
тисячі гривень щоб просто ця форма
перешити і вона все одно була не зручна